That just a few years later, the English in turn themselves chased out.
Where is it on the map? I want to see it on the map.
You want to see it on the map? Yeah, I want to see it on the map.
Oh, Georgia. We've talked about Georgia, of course.
Do you remember? It was in 1733 that General Oglethorpe, an idealist, landed there with about a hundred men who'd been in debtor's prison.
And they were Lutherans and Swiss and Scots and Jews and even women.
And together with them, they founded Savannah, Georgia.
One of you has to work with his own hands.
There will be no slaves, no alcohol.
As it happened a few years later,
in this period there are one and a half million Europeans on American soil,
but this population would double every 20 years or so.
As for cities, well, only a few ports were worthy of the name:
Boston, and Philadelphia, and New York, Charleston.
And all the rest were no more than, well, communities.
So 300,000 blacks in the South, who it's understood are supposed to be freed after six or seven years, but things didn't always work out that way.
Truth, Master, for 15 years I've worked for you. A long time ago I should have been freed. You know it's not right, Master.
But my goodness, what would become of you without me? You'd have to leave your family forever.
Here's a home roof over your head, plenty of food to eat here, you're all right.
And besides, you know you cost me at least one pound a year to clothe and feed.
Don't believe me, you're better off staying here with us.
Yes, I was a certainly fire plantation.
You think you've been loafing enough?
Get to work now. Go on. Go on.
What are you waiting for? Get to work, lazy.
You're no question about it. Slaves were very useful
for doing the very hard work on the cotton and tobacco plantations
because the Indians, they're fanatics for liberty
and they weren't docile enough when they were pressed into service earlier.
With its rebellious Indians and its black slaves,
the America, the 13 colonies, was looking for its identity,
but it went to extremes sometimes.
so it was that some regretted the lost purity of the pilgrims never forget
sinners the judgment has come on upon us all of you every one of you is a sinner
in the grip of an angry God now I will tell you the terrible torches of hail
that await you sinners know ye there will be no redemption no
remission in heaven for any who transgress the holy word of the Lord
Almighty repent repent you sinners repent in hell you miserable sinners will
roast in the depths of the inferno repent all of you repent now before it's
Before it's too late, what awaits you sinners!
Cast into the fire these wings these jewels can't go!
Cast into the purifying fire all these things of Satan!
Hallelujah!
This explosion, this great revival would soon burn out.
Fortunately, there were more reasonable voices that made themselves heard as well.
Benjamin Franklin, for example.
If I believe in the existence of God and the immortality of the soul,
my reason tells me that I have no need of any revelation.
Strange, I have the feeling that I've already known that chap.
Hmm.
Yes, you could meet the best and the worst in this America.
In the middle of the 18th century, the country was too new.
It needed a melting pot to forge itself into a true nation.
Oh, yes, for the present, what was there in common between this rich southern planter
with his plantation of thousands of acres or a Negro slave
or this poor northern farmer who has to do everything for himself?
And be sure we remember to cut planks and fix that leaky roof.
Oh, yes, Mary, and you remember to smoke the bacon and, every once in a while, add water to brew the beer.
Oh, yes, you can sure count on it, John, and the wagon. You have to fix the wheel, John, and chew the horse, too.
I know, Mary, but the livestock are looking poor. Give them more fodder.
Watch your wheel, John, just as soon as you bring in a nice crop of hay.
Yes, Mary, and remember to prepare the leather for my new boots and my wool jacket.
You'd better finish it soon. Nights are getting just a bit nippy.
And we will need wood to burn in the stove. It heats our whole house.
Let us thank the Lord.
Yes, John, for all his blessings on us.
And what did they have in common, those craftsmen in the cities?
Hmm?
The merchants, and the shopkeepers.
And especially, the frontiersmen, who are clearing the land, the pioneers, and more often than not, the adventurers.
What did they all have in common?
Nevertheless, a handful of men tried to draw together all these divergent interests, one notable among them.
Just a minute, I'm sure I know that chap.
Anyway, in Albany, in the year 1754...
It is essential for us to adopt a common policy concerning the Indians.
We must build our forts together, and we ourselves are responsible for our defense.
But, Mr. Franklin, the English soldiers defend us very well.
Yes, possibly, but gentlemen, this way we are like a snake cut up into segments.
The snake cannot live.
And neither can we if we do not unite.
This we must do.
Unite who with what?
You can only unite things that are alike.
I'm a Virginian, sir.
I failed to see what I could possibly have to do with people in New England.
No, it's a radical idea.
And those of us who live in perpetual harmony with the Lord, what would you have us do in company with those slave owners and those unscrupulous merchants?
I'll be united against the Indians, you see. The Indians, they're not such a big problem.
I'm telling you, I speak from experience as a frontiersman. Trash me.
We give you wonderful gifts. You give us furs.
For this junk, we let you use our land. But now we can hunt no more. Animal gone.
We no want this stuff. We want fire sticks. We shoot animals. No getaway.
If you want not give us rifle, then we go to French. They give us rifle.
Okay, you're right. Next time we'll bring you fire stitch or rifles, like you say.
But meanwhile, have a drink of whiskey, Chief. It warms a pretty's heart.
Let's drink a friendship, Big Chief.
I'll give Chief fire water.
Chief, take another swig.
Dear, you give Chief no fire water. You take it all. Take it all.
And one they won't forget. I'll be with those savage redskins.
I quite agree. They never live up to their agreements.
They're all treacherous savages.
I would even go so far as to say they're always blind drunk when they make their treatise.
Can it be true?
Yes, yes, exactly.
But how can we ever believe what they say?
All that you say is true.
Who could put them in this state?
Who would give them alcohol to make them agree to anything?
Tell me I want to know.
This has decreed that we settle here.
If the Indians oppose the great design, we must force them from the lands the Lord has given.
Blessed be Providence, my brothers.
Splendid doctrine that allowing you to massacre human beings whose souls are worth as much as ours.
Unless you gain riches from the toil of slaves, from their burden, their misery.
Wars in order to seize what they have, it is pillage and theft.
It is true that commerce is generally founded on deception.
Only cultivation of the land is virtuous, positive, honest, and above all, blessed by God.
Yeah, there you see, I told you, at that time in America, you found the worst and the best.
But Benjamin Franklin, master of oil, had other passionate interests other than politics and philosophy.
Say that lightning's only electricity, and I'll prove it.
You take your constitutionals in the rain now?
I'm going to perform an experiment of capital importance.
You're going to be with me, where you can help.
You'll see, my son, you'll see. This experiment will go down in history.
Be careful, whatever.
Okay.
Scientific electricity, son, you'll see soon.
Okay, I guess I will.
Son?
See, my son.
1763. The French have just abandoned their American possessions to the English.
Mrs. Revere. Morning, Paul.
Good day.
How's the engraving?
Oh, Ben Franklin and son, going very well, thank you.
Look here, Ben. An invention of yours works.
This way, it doesn't hit my house.
No, lightning is sent right into the ground.
Very clever, Ben, your lightning rod.
Bye, thanks again.
Do you know it's not allowed to make hats here?
Huh? What? Not allowed?
What do you mean, not allowed? You're joking?
The mysterious art of hat-making is now typically within the purview of the United Kingdom.
Where the enactment of profession has been attained,
it is forbidden to undertake any such manufacture beyond the territorial limits,
and more especially in America.
Any contravention will be punished.
I hope you have understood.
I don't want to see you making hats again.
Well, how do you like that?
Never heard such a thing before.
Don't you worry.
They won't get away with this.
What I know, just what you have in those sacks there.
Nothing but sugar, sir.
Sugar, that's all.
Why do you want to know that?
And does it come from England?
Of course not.
Nobody in England grows sugar.
It's too cold.
In that case, you mean it's from the Antilles, admit it.
I don't know.
To me, sugar, sugar, that's that.
I am confiscating your whole load of sugar.
It's all contraband.
Get down.
Let's go.
But...
How do you like that?
They even took my wagon.
Now what am I going to do to earn a living?
Well, there we are now.
They've put a tax on glass, paper, lead, paint.
Next, what is it going to be?
They'll make up enough taxes to squeeze us like lemons.
Those are cursed English.
Yes, now I've heard they're sending back our saddlers.
Now you can't even go west anymore.
It's not fair.
Who would hurt a certain thing?
This time the cup overfloweth, my friends.
Listen, it's incredible.
To take effect this day, residents of the 13 colonies
must buy and affix stamps on all newspapers,
almanacs, maritime documents, playing cards, dice, etc.
Dice as well?
Dice as well.
There are 50 items on the list.
I repeat, 50.
They've gone raving mad.
We won't pay taxes we haven't voted on.
No taxation without representation.
Down with the tyrant.
Governor, you are hereby ordered to pay a tax of threepence per pound on all the tea you carry or I confiscate your cargo.
But my company ordered me to transport this tea.
They didn't tell me I had to pay any tax.
He'll refuse.
We are the Sons of Liberty. We oppose any such payment.
It's an unfair tax!
I would suggest that you keep your opinions to yourself, Mr. Samuel Adams.
Understand, as a representative of the Crown, I maintain this ship must pay all taxes prescribed by the law.
Sir, we will see about.
Cast, now these colonies must either submit or defeat me. Do you understand?
This would-be subject of His Majesty George III dumped him to Boston Harbor to a value of £12,000 sterling.
In rebellion, we cannot tolerating of His Majesty's ordinances...
I shall order our troops to take action. Unmask the other rebels and arrest them.
And straight away, they will be expedited here and we will know how to judge them.
Yes, it is quite true. The British crowned it an intolerable injustice towards us all.
Gentlemen, I am Patrick Henry from Virginia, but I maintain there is now no difference between New York, Pennsylvania, New England.
We are all Americans. We must unite all together against the Redcoats.
Gentlemen, here's the resolution submitted to our assembly.
According to the eternal laws of nature, man has the right to life, liberty, and property.
These rites have never been ceded to a sovereign, that he should dispose of them without the people's consent.
Knew that one day, sooner or later, we would join together the segments of that snake.
The English are bristling with activity. We must be prepared for anything.
We will establish a militia, men ready to fight at a minute's notice.
Yes, we will call them Minute Men.
Paul, you will be responsible for training them. We count on you.
Good night, in your homes at work, you must be ready. Ready to answer the call at a minute's notice.
No more. That's why your rifles should always be loaded.
My dear Susie, I would like to ask you a big favor.
You think the time is right?
But what exactly do you want?
It's this.
I have to be up and dressed and ready to fight in a minute.
Tonight, wake me up.
Say one minute, but only one minute.
One minute?
Only one minute?
Hmm?
The other.
That makes six minutes, dear.
Pick up a lot of time if I sleep dressed sitting in my armchair.
That'll do for now.
This was only a practice.
Well, if you're sure it was only a practice, Ron, can I go back to bed?
It's an excellent strategy to attack their warehouses in Concord.
I believe that they will not soon forget the lesson we will teach them.
Anything less would hardly be to our credit.
These rebels are no more than paper-ta-
Oh, yes, General Cage was speaking of them the other day.
They are lions, only so long as we treat them as sheep.
But this time, we shall turn them into lambs.
British are here, Paul. They're in the swamp by the hundreds.
We heard them. They're gonna try to blow up a warehouse in Concord.
William draws run and warn all the men of Boston.
neck to lexington and i'll take a small boat and rush to charleston they're all one the others
we'll show them the stuff we're made of they won't get away with it to shoot if it's war they want
let it begin here until you see the whites of their eyes huh sweep them away make smite of them
could you lend me some here we shall never purchase peace at the price of slave chains
almighty god grant us victory we would rather die as free men than live on our knees no yes patrick
Henry spoke truly, the British didn't know it, but a bloody eight-year war was only beginning.